kelly is in pittsburgh hey kelly how are
you
i'm doing well thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
okay so first i have to tell you it's
just a privilege to talk to you sir my
husband and i
uh several years ago took fpu at our
church and it
it completely changed our life we paid
off about 150
000 dollars in debt which was mostly my
big giant school look
and uh now we've been through baby step
four and maybe step five
and we're getting ready to start six and
uh
covet sort of hit my job is as secure i
think as a job
really can be in today's time uh my
husband works in sales though so he's
pretty much
taken a big giant hit but we can live
off of my income alone
but sort of where we are now we have
everything ready we did one little bit
of stupid and we still have that hanging
out which is a vehicle lease
it is up in august and i've done
we've done a lot of research on what
type of vehicle
and we have the money saved but we're
sort of just really struggling with
spending that much on a vehicle i know
we're leasing and it's completely stupid
but
sort of where we are if we have our
emergency fund our six-month emergency
fund is about 30 000
and we have 60 in the bank and
i have uh we've picked out it's a 2014
vehicle and from the research i did
essentially for what what type of
vehicle we need to get our three kids in
car seats in the back
it's a lexus gs or i'm sorry a gx as far
as uh
maintaining its as much value as it can
because it's a vehicle and just safety
and and the cost
for maintenance and things like that so
that would run at about 25
000. i just feel super guilty about
paying that much and i'm thinking should
we
only buy like kind of a clunker for five
instead
or should we your household not counting
covet what's your household income
um our household income we're less is uh
anywhere from you know 175 to 200.
what's the other car worth
uh my the one that's leased no the one
the other car you have two cars don't
you
okay yes i i don't even know
what it is roughly ten thousand or a
hundred thousand
no no ten thousand maybe okay
all right so you'd have 35 000 in cars
if you bought a 25 and this one's worth
10.
right yes you have the cash to pay for
it
you make 175 000 a year
yeah my husband again
okay i that's i okay i
understand we're wasting way more money
than that on a lease but
we've never bought like a big adult
purchase that cost
that much before so yeah have you just
paid for it in the form of a lease
that's true that's true well in fact yes
what we've paid for at least essentially
over all these years if we would have
added that in a total lump sum
we could buy this vehicle yeah and
uh yeah easy yeah so um yeah
so here's the thing here's what happens
you went
from being and sharon and i experienced
the same thing
you went from being irresponsible you
worked your way out of the mess by
becoming
uber responsible hyper responsible
careful and tight you worked your way
out of the mess
and you're and now you're have developed
a really strong financial position
but your emotions are still back there
when you were
being gazelle intense
yes that's probably right after we took
fpu probably after the debt snowball
class yeah
i mean we went from real normal to real
weird real quick
and this feels this feels weird you're
this is yeah this purchases beyond your
emotions you've experienced that
you know it's funny because i was just
talking about this on the christy wright
show just uh this week with the episode
that aired this week we're talking about
money
and i said something happened to me in
my 20s where it used to be
the mindset was if i have the money i
should buy it there was no reason not to
buy something if the money was
physically in my account
and then i started to realize oh if i
lived that way i'm never going to have
any money
and so when i started to pay off my debt
and become debt free and change my
mindset
i started to value having money in my
account more than the stuff
well once you make that switch even if
you want the thing it's still hard to
write that check she may want the car
but man it feels good to have that 25
000 in my account
that's hard to let go of when you switch
to valuing actually stockpiling some
cash and having some cash
so that's probably a little bit of
what's going on too exactly what it is
the the cash is giving you more
emotional
psychological satisfaction than the car
although you have dialed this car
completely in i mean the way you
described it you have completely bought
this car
yeah i mean you you are you are way way
down there you're down the lexus
rabbit hole no question you sound like a
lexus salesman when you're done
i don't have to be i i know i'm not
making fun of you i'm just making fun of
you
i was so worried like by which i my
husband and i have talked i called
yesterday and never
not got to talk to you and i said i
don't really know why
i need to call i know exactly where
we've been doing this long enough for
years and i know what he's going to say
what did you think did i say what you
thought i was going to say
yes yes and i said i'm worried that
there's not a warranty
and i said he's going to say baby girl
your warranty is in the bank in cash
guaranteed it's right there that's
exactly right by the way if you get
if you buy a certified lexus on the on
their lot it'll have a warranty with it
but
that's included in the price don't buy
an extended warranty you know that as
well you know all the answers to these
questions
um and uh by the way sharon hold our
kids around that same car for a few
years it's a good car
actually i actually own two of those
over my life
i've had two of those that exact car
they're very very they're they're great
cars
and they're powerful they got a big v8
in them which is they they'll go
too so keep your foot out of it but yeah
it's it's still hard to let go that
money when we um were pregnant with uh
mary grace last summer i had to get
upgrade my v i had a little lexus
rx 350 a little you know uh one one row
in the back seat and i want to have two
rows for the for all the
15 car seats it felt like and uh and we
went to to find one we ended up getting
behind a pilot with the three rows
and they said the same thing they're
like oh you know this warranty that
warranty i was like i work for dave
ramsey he's like i'm not going to waste
my breath
all right good okay i'm not in the mood
i don't want to hear it but yeah it's
still hard to write that check even if
you have it
once you value the money but yeah you
need that and you'll be glad you have it
kelly yeah we've even experienced that
in business
that as the numbers here have come up in
this this company will bring in 250
million dollars this year
and uh i can't wrap my emotional head
around that still
intellectually i can grasp it yeah but
we spend more on copier paper
here than i spent on the entire first
year probably you know with
with a thousand employees and so it i
just can't get my head around what we
spent on coffee
yeah you know i can't get my head around
the stuff and not emotionally now
intellectually i can go oh well that you
know that makes sense with that many
people that you got this and that
but your emotions don't catch up and
that's what happens as you go through
these
different stages of wealth building you
go from
uh you know deep in debt
and oblivious to where then you
understand what's going on and you get
that gazelle intensity and then you move
up and
you know your emotions it just takes
them a while to catch up yeah
yeah that's good you get to run you get
to running so hard
and you're so dialed in with it yeah
very good
we're proud of you she needs it and
she'll she'll be glad she has it yeah
she did a great job
yeah that's really good i mean they paid
off a ton of debt yeah we're making big
money
she's done her research on the car she
knows what she wants knows what she
needs
ready to go